Patrick is in Ohio hi Patrick welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show good afternoon
Dave how you doing this afternoon better
than I deserve what's up in your world
I think they ask you a two-fold question
I've uh I've worked at 3:43 on companies
and they did have 401ks but none of them
had a match and the people I've been in
the one I've been and I was in one for a
little bit and I got out of it I didn't
think it was doing real real well and
some other co-workers said the same
thing and they drop theirs and I was
just wondering if if it's always a good
thing to be in a company 401k that maybe
doesn't matter you don't feel that the
performance is good and my second
question is is government's always in
our business but what what happens if
the government offered some type of of
retirement where we were able to put
something in tax-free attached the bird
and we had a guaranteed 4% I know that's
not you know a six to a 12% that maybe
after a historical return of you know
over years but it always tucked away at
never lost and it would give people
confidence to put something in because
they would see it maybe always growing
versus that it's up one month and down
the next well that doesn't exist unless
you're talking about some kind insuring
me today the government doesn't have
that sounds like you really wouldn't
really don't whatever if you put it you
just pull up a calculator online and put
in a hundred dollars a month at 10% or
12% and then put in a hundred dollars a
month at 4% and you'll see real quickly
why you don't want to do that it's a
bazillion dollars difference I mean it's
not four times as much it's a hundred
times as much because when you're
talking yeah when you're talking about
compound interest it works on a curve it
does not work on a straight line and so
you know
12% is not three times as much as 4%
it's more like 30 times as much and so
it blows your mind how much a few
percentage points makes so you would
never take that low percentage as far as
the 401k goes here's the thing to
remember the 401k itself is not an
investment it is how the investment is
treated under Section 401 K section 401
subsection K of the IRS code meaning
that you're allowed to have money taken
out of your check and put into an
investment pre-tax and then it grows
tax-free if it's a Roth 401 K tax
deferred if it's a regular 401 K now
what's been underperforming is not the
actual 401 K it's more like the code
that is keeping the investment warm it's
the investment inside the coat that
sucked
if you had an underperforming 401 K what
you really have is an underperforming
investment in your 401 K does that make
sense
what do you mean by that
okay pretend I could pretend like
pretend like there's a cookie jar and
that's the investment with the cookies
the cookies in the cookie jar are either
good or bad the jar doesn't determine
that the jar is just where you park the
cookies that makes sense yes you get up
peanut butter cookies you could have
sugar cookies you could have chocolate
chip cookies and they could be good
cookies or they could suck but the jar
didn't cause any of that to happen the
jars just where you have them the 401 K
is the jar the investment is the cookies
so we basically three places I've worked
that they didn't really have the right
and best or you didn't pick the right
ones from the ones that they offered why
there was four on each one of them now
there was four there are four general
portfolios on each one of them and you
picked the wrong portfolio but you
probably could have gone even inside of
those four portfolios meaning they had a
they had a low risk a medium risk and a
high risk or something like that
and that high risk
I've had a group of mutual funds in it
that would have sounded a lot like what
we tell you to do and you would have
done a lot better had you been in that
versus the one you were in and so what
you're looking for is you're looking for
mutual funds inside the 401k whether
there's a match or not
a match is helpful obviously because
it's freaking free money but you're
looking for mutual funds inside the 401k
that have a good long-term track record
and I personally in my 401k here at my
business do this and I recommend that
other people do the same thing that you
put it in four types of mutual funds
growth growth and income aggressive
growth and international and that's the
cookies okay that's the you summon a
chocolate-chip cookie you want some
peanut butter cookie you want some sugar
cookie and so on right some Oreos or
whatever I'm just making this up as I go
here but the pup the bottom line is is
that you're trying to get different
kinds of investments that have good
long-term track records and they fall
under the heading of growth stock mutual
funds in side the 401 K you can also do
that inside a Roth and if you don't like
the options that your company has
available to you to invest inside the
401 K and there's no match then you
could go to a just a Roth IRA
do the exact same thing and pick from
any of 8,000 mutual funds so certainly
you could get a good one that way and if
you need some help doing that or even
selecting the stuff inside your 401 K
the people we recommend in the
investment world we call smart Wester
pros and if you go to smart investor at
Dave Ramsey com click on that it'll drop
down a little filling the blank thing
you fill in your stuff it'll drop down a
list of the people that we recommend in
your area the smart investor pros and
then you can sit down with them they'll
have the heart of a teacher not the
heart of a Salesman and you'll hear
stuff very similar to what I just
outlined to you here and you know the
different different types of mutual
funds that have long track records
growth growth and income aggressive
growth and international